well this feels about a million miles
from the grandeur of blenheim we're in a
suburb of beijing north eastern suburb
here
a suburb where a lot of artists spend
their time one of the my way way this is
his studio it's his home and it's also
effectively his prison he's not allowed
to leave beijing he certainly can't
leave the country his passport was taken
away from him back in 2011 when he was
arrested at beijing airport put in
detention in jail
for 81 days 81 days that he says were
hellish
up here is the sign
representing his company which is called
fake his artistic studio and it is that
company that was fined uh back in 2012
many millions of chinese yuan they
charged him the government charged him
uh for fraud many say that's just a
catch-all phrase to get him out of the
limelight stop him from his criticism of
the chinese government and here is a
bicycle chained always to this tree and
inside every morning he comes out and
puts flowers in fresh flowers in there
to represent every day that he's been
under house arrest and i think more
broadly those flowers represent all
those thousands of people across china
who criticize uh the government and for
that they are detained he this
exhibition represents a milestone for
him because once it's taken place it
will be it will mean that he has been
unable to attend more exhibitions than
those he has been able to go to because
he's not allowed to leave the country
and although at the moment there is no
heavy police presence here there was
once a police car parked outside here
when he was under full house arrest
that's gone but there is still if you
can see up behind me there a cctv camera
he's still watched he is absolutely
clear that he's still watched everywhere
he goes